So this week we're talking about archaeology, and we asked your students in the
introduction activity to produce their signature.
Kind of a strange thing to do, right?
So do your signature. There's my mess of a signature.
And we asked them to do that multiple times.
Well, why?
Because when an archaeologist is digging, and what archaeologists do
is if you have an excavation site, you have to dig
below.
Well, what happens when a city falls?
It crumbles to the ground. It all falls in.
Well, it's not like today where if this whole entire building came down that we
would clear the rubble, send it to recycling facilities and rebuild
and level the ground and start all over again.
They didn't have those capabilities so if a city fell and all the rubble sat here
they would simply level off the rubble and build a new city right on top
and it would keep doing that year after year after year or decade after decade or
whatever the case may be so as archaeologists are digging they're digging below
each of these levels each is called uh it's an archaeological tell is what they call
it and they're digging into well they have to use clues to figure out if they
started digging here and they found something that's going to be from a different
time period than if they dug down here and found something.
So the signature is a way for your students to help understand that
if they found a piece of paper with my signature on it
and they figured out that it was me with this big mess of a signature, they would
know that, let's see, based on the fact that I used an Expo marker, the fact that
I'm on a whiteboard, the fact that it's black, all these factors, plus they would
connected to me could figure out roughly the date or at least close to
when this actually happened. Let me give you another example.
This is the Hulkbuster and full disclosure, this is mine, not my kids.
If this whole building collapsed, let's say we were in the ancient times and they
had Legos in ancient times, and this whole building collapsed and they found pieces
of this, and they put it back together and discovered that it was this.
Based on the kind of Lego this is, based on the character, the fact that this is
Iron Man in the Hulkbuster suit, that they would pretty much know exactly
when this Lego came out, roughly when it got built, and
what era they're currently digging in.
So that's the importance in kind of what archaeologists do.
And we want your students to start thinking about what that looks like.
Okay, this isn't necessarily Indiana Jones kind of stuff, but it gives us a good
idea of how this is done. So when they come across biblical artifacts, what does
that mean for the biblical text?
So for your storyteller, this is a really cool opportunity to have someone come
in. You don't have to have an archaeologist.
You don't have to have anybody that has an amazing discovery.
If you can, that would be awesome.
If you happen to have somebody in a local seminary that has done some traveling to
the Middle East and Jerusalem and whatnot, that'd be awesome.
But if not, that's okay. Don't worry like you have to have that.
You can simply have somebody that was rummaging around in grandma's attic and found
a really important family heirloom.
Years ago, my grandma was moving from her condo to a long-term
care facility because she was getting ill and needed to be watched pretty much 24
-7. So my family all got together, and we were kind of going through all of our
stuff. It's a little bit weird when she's sitting there watching us go through all
of her stuff, but it was fascinating because we found all these really cool
artifacts, and there were stories behind it, and it was stuff that reminded my dad
of his childhood and kind of what that meant, and we talked about really interesting
stories, and we had a really great time walking down those memories.
But if you could just find a storyteller to even tell that story, it helps connect
the importance of discovery and archaeology and artifacts and all those pieces of
history with what we can know about the Bible.
Because my dad can tell me a story, but when he connects it with an artifact
or something from his past, that story becomes that much more reliable.
because it could just be he remembered it wrong, but it also becomes that much more
powerful because I'm understanding that what he's telling me is now actually
history. And that's exactly what we're helping your students get when they look at
archaeology and scripture. So for small groups, your focus is simple.
I want you to focus on helping students see that this Bible is also
history.
Yeah, it's the word of God. Yes, it's inspired.
Yes, it's completely accurate in every way because God made it that way.
But God also made this a accurate reflection of history.
What goes on in here is actually historical.
We have found coins that give us indication that David actually was a king.
And we've seen things from the New Testament that have the inscription of Pontius
Pilate on it that remind us that Pontius Pilate was an actual person.
He was an actual governor. He actually was the one responsible during Jesus'
crucifixion.
There is history behind it all. And we want your students to kind of drill that in.
But I also want you to pay attention to their questions because now that they're
starting to see scripture as something that's a little bit more important than maybe
they thought it was there's going to be some pushback and some thought that well
isn't this just a bunch of stories and myths that maybe people thought were true and
there's some sort of evidence that maybe they just kind of messed around with
history and they just kind of messed around with the truth a little bit.
There's going to be questions and you need to be ready to answer those questions and
talk through them a little bit but I want you to continue to walk students down that
road of helping them understand and see the importance of this book and what it
means for their lives. So I'm going to leave you with one final question that I want
you to leave your students with.
Two weeks in, what does this information from the biblical reliability
to archaeological evidence do
for how you see the Bible?
Think about that for yourself, because if you didn't know some of this
information prior to these last couple of weeks and now moving forward with your
students, think about that with yourself.
Does this change how you see it?
And don't be afraid to share this with your students and help them see like, hey, I
didn't know either. Maybe I didn't know all of this.
Maybe I'm not. This is new information for you as well.
Share that with your students. Walk alongside them, especially encourage your small
group leaders to do the same thing so that they can see that this isn't something
that they ought to know and everybody should know and they're just kind of out of
the loop. That this is a journey for all of you and the more you understand, the
greater that this book becomes.